when you're in that hidden season it's
really hard like why am i working on a
youtube channel i got this job i got
this pressure i got the stuff i got
freelance clients so many times when i
doubted what i was even doing but
that was the season where i was creating
the momentum that was the season that
solopreneur season is extra hard
because you're not just doing your
full-time job or your full-time
responsibilities you have to be that
much more disciplined to pull off the
side hustle stuff
so part of being a content creator is
going through different seasons where
you feel like you're putting in a ton of
work a ton of hustle and you're not
really seeing those big results yet if
this is you i want you to know that we
see you we know what it's like and can
it be real it's actually really hard and
in today's episode we're going to be
talking about that season and how you
can actually capitalize in that season
to move you into youtube success my name
is heather torres and i am the host of
the think media podcast the number one
podcast to help you grow your influence
on youtube and then turn that influence
into a high profit and a high income
online business now if you are just
joining us for the first time welcome to
the podcast make sure you subscribe
wherever you get this podcast on and if
you are on youtube right now i want to
say please hit that like button and let
me know in the comment section where are
you watching from now this episode is
brought to you by our
thinkholidaysale.com
this is an amazing thing we have right
now during the holiday season for you we
have our brand new course and so many
bonuses for you at over 80 percent off
we're teaching you how to get to your
first 1000 subscribers and earn your
first 1 000 and beyond on
youtube this is brand new so if you've
not seen it yet you can go to
thinkholidaysale.com
to get all the information and take
advantage of 80 off of this holiday sale
now we are in the middle of a five part
series called taking the leap on last
week's episode we talked about the law
of preparation that was law number one
and now we're heading into law number
two and in this episode we've broken it
into a few different sections and
section number one is actually from one
of our grow with video live which is our
annual conference sessions that sean did
so we're doing a little bit of that and
then afterwards shawn and i come on and
we actually expand more into the law of
preparation and the law of momentum
actually just a lot of momentum on this
one last episode we did the law of
preparation so uh you're gonna have
those two parts and then i'll come back
on and we'll recap together at the very
end so let's jump into part two of the
leap to full time
[Music]
the law of
momentum
see i had built momentum during the side
hustle
season
okay now in john maxwell's book the 21
irrefutable laws of leadership he talks
about the law of the big mo
and the law of the big mo boosts your
success see momentum is more natural to
steer than to start
can't steer a parked car it's actually
hard to start and keep things going it's
hard to get things going but once you
have them going now it's time to steer
the momentum right
so once you get things moving
momentum is the most potent change agent
is what john maxwell says so the reason
i say this is you right now in this
moment really listen to me for this part
you are possibly in the hardest season
you're going to be in on your journey to
youtube success
now
it's really impossible to compare the
seasons but i think about today and if i
let you into my life a little bit
i am feeling a sigh of relief because we
have the think media team around me and
us we've got uh we've got support around
us we've got a community uh around us
but even specifically when it comes to
team and support like it's not all on my
shoulders anymore like we are carrying
these things together the truth is
during my solopreneur season i probably
got less credit than i deserved
because people had no idea what i was
doing and hit and how hard i was really
working
but now i probably get more credit than
i deserve because you don't realize how
remarkable the think media team is and
those around me and they just make me
look good
but here's the point when you're in that
hidden season i get it man
it's freaking lonely
it's really hard
you want to give up a lot
you want to quit all the time
you're tired you feel pressure from
every side you don't think it's going to
work you're putting in so many hours and
you're getting so little views
five years
like why am i working on a youtube
channel i got this job i got this
pressure i got the stuff i got freelance
clients so many times when i doubted
what i was even doing
but
that was the season where i was creating
the momentum
that was the season that solopreneur
season is extra hard
because you're not just doing your
full-time job or your full-time
responsibilities you have to be that
much more disciplined to pull off the
side hustle stuff
and
during that side hustle season
i started to
earn a thousand dollars per month i got
up to a thousand dollars a month at
affiliate marketing so here's my real
numbers so i figured out my business
model i'm talking about tech i'm i'm
reviewing tech uh i'm understanding
youtube's the search engine i'm
following the seven r's i'm developing
that whole system you go back to june
2015 i had a 350 a month um it then goes
to 764.
and by you know even by the month of
october i had a really good month i had
1
57 come in on amazon then it dropped to
a thousand so that
that debit of 3 000 was two months
combined you could see that in november
and so
in 2015
during that time
i i this this was money coming in right
it's legitimate money what i want you to
hear again
you probably realize that a thousand
dollars depending on your situation if
you've got mouths to feed you've got a
mortgage rent
it's money but it's not like that's not
enough depending on where you live and
what not like this certainly
we need it about i mean of course you
got to live on whatever you got to live
on but the median income in the u.s is
about 52 000 for dual income averaged
across the whole us punch line that's
five times short from that
but the other side of the coin is that's
also real momentum
one of the keys of knowing when to take
the leap
is knowing that you already have some
momentum right and then you go okay
now like john maxwell says the law of
the big mo
momentum is easier to steer than it is
to start
because that's what david saw he was
like dude
you can go
you know i'm on the phone he's like
because listen you've been doing this
for other people you've been doing this
for other clients now you're going to
focus all on this you're going to be
surprised when you focus all your energy
full time
on going uh all in on youtube write this
down if you're looking for even a metric
it's called the 25 rule
first step one how much money do you
need to live a month
to support you and your dependents write
that down and i don't mean like to pay
your ferrari bill return the ferrari i
don't even mean to pay for your 65 000
suv return that and get a certified
pre-owned uh car that's a couple years
old like really lower your lifestyle if
you really are serious about this and so
twenty-five percent rule
what how much do you need to live a
month let's say four thousand you write
your number down though how much you
need to uh live a month if it's four
thousand dollars
and from your side hustle you have
proven over
three four five six months
that you can consistently generate 25
of your needed amount to live on per
month
that could be an indicator it's time to
take the leap
now don't email me if all of a sudden
that doesn't work out for you but listen
like that's why because it's the law of
momentum there's a little bit of
momentum going there so now when you put
in your two weeks at work now when you
go all in
now you have that moment to say okay now
the only thing i'm focusing on which was
the only thing i was focusing on was
working on my youtube business and i
went all in with that law of momentum
you know you look at this and on october
12th
2015
that that day i got 1
861 views
today i think we get about 125 000 views
a day on think media
so when you compare those that's nothing
but you'd probably relate you probably
you're like that's amazing so what i'm
trying to encourage you is there's not
some magic number but the point is you
have some momentum one of the biggest
mistakes i see people take with taking
the leap is they haven't done the
preparation yet and they don't have the
momentum yet and so you still might want
to stay anchored in your job and keep
working your skills invest just as hard
work just as hard but stay in that
preparation season keep learning keep
immersing yourself keep posting videos
when you can keep practicing
and then a power question
is
what momentum can you celebrate
i want you to celebrate the momentum
that you have
so ultimately
you want to
stoke the fire and you want to feed the
flame you want to what momentum can you
celebrate and what momentum can you
capitalize on
what momentum can you
uh you notice you go oh that's working
like success leaves clues make part twos
that video is working let me do more of
those
but what momentum can you celebrate i
want you to schedule a party if you've
been if you just hit 100 subscribers and
by party i mean
get a red box red box dude it's all
digital now bro what are you talking
about get you know schedule a night with
your loved ones or by yourself get
yourself your favorite candy and say
it's a 100 subscriber celebration night
like you want to celebrate momentum
along the way because momentum is real
whether that's a thousand views a day
whether that's 100 views a day whether
that's 10 views a day whether that's
getting your first subscriber because
you want to recognize momentum
and then you want to capitalize on
momentum and keep going deeper on it so
how do you know when to take the leap
when is it actually the right time to
take that scary move and quit your nine
to five we just watched that clip or
listened to that clip from growth video
live on the law of momentum and i really
do think that one of the indicators of
going full time on youtube when you
should take the leap is do you have
momentum the 25 rule do you have at
least a portion of your needed monthly
expenses
being covered by your side hustle and uh
this opens up some interesting things
about what it takes though to create
momentum and i kind of got real there i
know that during our event that was an
emotional moment of really just kind of
going into the loneliness
of
not having the full time yet not having
the subscribers yet not having it yet
doing really hard work in the unseen
season
what did that kind of bring to mind for
you yeah first off can we just applaud
five years like you did that for five
years most people quit after 90 days you
know so the idea of the law momentum is
that it doesn't happen overnight it's
not like you're just gonna wake up one
day and have six-pack abs no you gotta
like eat the salad run the runs you
gotta do those things and really when i
think about the law of momentum uh one
of the passions that i really wanna get
into is gardening and when i think about
the law of momentum with gardening
there's so much that happens prior to
you actually harvesting your vegetables
there is tilling the soil there's making
sure there's the right nutrients in it
there's planting there's watering
there's all of these things that you're
just doing behind the scenes no one sees
it it just looks like a plot of land or
just a a dirt pile but over time you
then grow this amazing garden now when i
pick up you know gardening books trying
to look in it i'm seeing these beautiful
raised planter boxes with all these
different vines and i'm thinking how
much work that was for that person to
get to that point
but over time as you start doing it more
and more and more it starts to actually
become easier it's the snowball effect
like once you know how to like grow
tomatoes it's easier to then grow
zucchini right and the same thing is is
like this for youtube that it's going to
take some time and it's going to be
lonely there's just going to be seasons
where you are doing it by yourself and
you feel like is this the right thing to
do you're questioning yourself over and
over but when you stick at it when you
stick at anything there's going to be
success on the other side and and even
where you are right now we are still in
a momentum season right it's still going
over and over and over and it just to me
i think that it's that that time period
where can you dig in can you
really plant can you know that there's
something germinating under the soil and
know that it's going to produce fruit
one day
yeah i think that's one of the
secrets to going full time on youtube is
not being surprised by things getting
hard i think people get surprised they
think i and maybe that's because of bad
marketing and kind of a generation where
we expect everything overnight we see
the full-time youtuber lifestyle we read
about one unicorn story about how
somebody did something in six months or
a year or just those which are cool and
that might happen to you but it probably
won't
and yet it's a lot more practical to put
in the the long haul the painstaking
preparation that it takes to build
momentum what emotions can you remember
or what emotions come to mind for you
in the different seasons of preparation
we're seeing just just nothing like no
accolades nobody's cheering nobody's
clapping and you want to give up like
what emotions come to mind for you yeah
for me um because i've talked about it
in the in the previous episode of this
one was um i just had such low
self-confidence that i was like i'm not
good enough for this
i don't know enough for this i'm not
smart enough for this and i just
remember you're right that feeling of it
this is just hard like all of this is
hard and why am i even doing this like
why does it have to be so difficult i
actually just felt like a failure over
and over and over i literally felt like
other people can do this and i can't and
i couldn't figure out what it was i like
what was the difference between the
person who i'd pull up on instagram and
was like
winning it life all the time and i'm
over here forty thousand dollars in debt
i dropped out of college um you know
we're we're moving we're having babies
like i'm doing all these things and like
nothing is quote unquote working and i
just felt so
unqualified for what i knew i was
supposed to be doing and it just felt
like i was just failing over and over
and over and then
it's like this weird magical thing that
happens it's just all of a sudden you
get a win and then you get another win
and you get another win and you're like
oh
this is what they're talking about right
like oh
this is how it goes and it just becomes
more and more about seeing there's still
failures along the journey but you start
to see that those sacrifice seasons
those seasons of feeling like i'm not
good enough for this all of a sudden
turned into oh wow i can do this
yeah 100
and you know i think that when you
actually think about momentum even in
like physics and i i think about it as a
rocket launch you know when there's a
rocket launch now that's the most latest
trend right billionaires go into space
so richard branson's launching jeff
bezos is launching elon's launch and
spacex well
the amount of jet fuel when the rocket
is sitting on the ground
the amount of rocket fuel that they burn
up is like almost the majority just to
get the rocket going initially to try to
break through the karman line and break
out into outer space right and so it's
actually similar to just what it takes
to launch any new venture and i think i
hope that the think media podcast uh
community could be encouraged by
like sometimes it's you almost are like
is this normal i'm so tired yes i'm like
spending so much money
i i'm working so hard
and fire is blowing everywhere and uh
it's really loud and everything is
shaking like a rocket
and and i'm barely moving like it's it's
like and i don't have any velocity yet i
don't have any speed yet that is what
john maxwell was saying in the law of
the big mo the law of momentum
that it is very hard to start momentum
but then eventually you get to steer it
and so the two big takeaways i think i
want people to have in this episode is
number one you're not alone
in that of how hard it is like anyone
who's built that full-time career and
built a real youtube entrepreneur
business and built a real online
business
uh if they're there now they've paid the
price yesterday yeah and they've they've
had those seasons where they've been
working
disproportionately hard on
building momentum i also heard uh one
leader say you know kind of secondly
that actually the the two scariest
things in life
are a lack of momentum
and momentum that the other thing is
like actually once you get it like
there's a whole other thing we'll be
talking i mean there's a this is just
part two of this five part series but i
think like today we have momentum at
think media it's terrifying like it's
you know it's the two most scary things
in life when you don't have it how am i
going to pay the bills how am i but then
also once it starts happening energy
kind of flips but on this journey to
full time
a couple questions what can you
celebrate right now can you celebrate
the momentum that you have that's like
getting down you said gardening you look
at the soil and a tiny little leaf has
popped through a tiny little growth has
popped through what your hope that you
get is an oak tree you want the full
trunk you want the full branches you
want all the leaves and the fruit of the
tree
but all you're seeing is just the
beginning kind of reminds me of
biblically in zachariah it's like do not
despise small beginnings yeah celebrate
a tiny bit of momentum whoa i just got
my first subscriber wow i just got my
first video that gets 10 views every
week that's a ranked video like it's got
a little bit of suggested traffic coming
in it's got a little bit i just got my
first i just made my first sale in
amazon affiliate income and my online
income wow i'm actually making 25
bucks a month on on online income that's
all momentum celebrate that mentum and
then how can we capitalize on that
momentum those are the bright spots what
can i look at that has momentum we have
to ask ourselves that today and think
media too there might be some things
that we actually want to steer our
energy away from because we've worked so
hard on them and they just haven't
really taken on that velocity that we
want
where we should be shifting is what is
going well though yeah why do these five
videos not do well i i keep making more
of the same videos it's just not working
what about the two in your library that
are let's double down on on the things
that are that celebrate small wins but
what can we also capitalize to keep
momentum going that's going to help us
go full time faster yeah and you just
hit it right on the head sean when you
said you know what is working and when i
look at the distinction between people
who are winning in our community and
people who are not winning in our
community right now they're actually
always looking at the positive i mean we
are blessed that we can build online
businesses from the comfort of our home
with free tools like youtube and when
you come at it as like oh my gosh 25
people can you imagine you in a room
teaching to 25 people
when has that ever happened before you
know and so the idea that 25 people 100
people maybe you did you got your first
affiliate check that is proof that it
works you know and so the people that
are winning are actually celebrating
their wins and this was something that
was difficult for me to do because i was
with the defeated mindset for so long
where i just thought oh this is again
back to i'm just not really good at this
oh man i did that video and it sucks and
i would think that and now i've shifted
into the victory mindset and i freaking
posted a video like you know and and wow
look at we're we're we're doing this
thing like people showed up you know
maybe it wasn't the amount of people but
people showed up and so how can you flip
that mindset from being in that defeated
victim mentality of this isn't working
for me the algorithms against me
everything's not you know versus man i'm
gonna i'm gonna work the system i'm
gonna figure out the algorithm i'm gonna
be around people who know how to do this
because that's when you start to see
people are celebrating all the time this
is a huge opportunity and it's the
little pieces and then when you start to
get to bigger things you're like really
celebrating and i and to me
the little wins are as big as the big
wins now i mean it's so much of building
momentum in even understanding how to
celebrate small things before you get to
the big things super strong man the
first episode right in this series we
talked about the law of practice and
preparation the second episode we talked
about the law of momentum i'm excited
because in the next episode we're going
to be talking about the law of sacrifice
that sounds painful i don't know if
anyone wants to stick around for that
one but we're super committed that's our
mission here at think media is to help
ten thousand purpose-driven people
create a full-time living doing what
they love
while making a difference in the world
with youtube and online video and i
really believe this the the the nuances
from my journey uh in doing this but
also your journey because all of our
paths are a little bit different we can
glean some um transferable principles
that i believe stay the same hence law
and by the way we didn't make up these
laws but i mean other great leaders in
business you know whether it's brian
tracy or john maxwell or these are like
extrapolated principles from great
businesses great youtube channels and so
when we anchor around these i think we
can find some commonality that these are
truly like tools they're going to help
us get to our goals so stick around in
the series definitely check out a past
episode uh episode one if you haven't
yet in this five part series and i'm
excited for the next one
well i hope you got value out of today's
episode and i have a question for you
what action do you need to take next
we're talking all about the law of
momentum so what momentum can you
celebrate you know it really is about
celebrating those small wins along the
way and when you do that you'll start to
see that those small wins will end up
being big
victories so write down in your journal
what are five wins that you can
celebrate this week maybe you got your
video uploaded maybe you signed your
first brand deal or maybe you bought the
camera that's gonna level up your
production whatever those wins are i
want you to celebrate them because as
you go along this journey i can tell you
that it's actually the small wins to me
that mean the most yeah the big
victories yes getting the you know
accolades like the play buttons and the
and the numbers of subscribers but
really it's about those small wins it's
about things like this like i'm sitting
down to record this podcast and this is
my win for today so write down those
wins uh in your journal so that you can
be keeping track of them throughout this
year and i want to let you know that uh
every week we read one of your reviews
over on apple itunes so if you want to
rate and review the podcast you can do
that over on apple and you might be
featured on one of our podcasts and
today it comes from scar man he says
love this podcast they cover everything
you need to know to create a youtube
channel love sean the most okay scar man
you and i we can have beef together but
i think sean's pretty cool too so uh
he's super witty and he shares honest
useful information that keeps you coming
back for more between this podcast and
their youtube channel and video ranking
academy there is a complete encyclopedia
of info to inspire and answer all of
your questions skarman
even though sean's your favorite and
your team sean it's okay thank you so
much for
this comment and i would love to be able
to read one of your comments so share
over on itunes and what this does for us
is it just allows for people who are
maybe in that
itunes searching for a different podcast
that they want to listen to
people read these comments and they want
to know what type of information they're
going to get if they're going to invest
their time in this podcast so i want to
thank you the think community for
showing up for us and we want to be here
to show up for you so not only do we
have this podcast but we also are
uploading bonus episodes over on our
youtube channel so make sure you're
subscribed over there as well that's
think media podcast over on youtube i
want to thank you so much for listening
today being a part of what we're doing
here at think media we're just getting
started inside of this series so if you
want to make sure you have your
notifications on so when next week part
three comes out you'll be ready for that
on our tuesday ritual i'll catch it in
the next episode bye did you see
thinkmediasale.com
for the holidays we're giving you eighty
percent off our brand new youtube made
simple course bundle
get over one thousand nine hundred
dollars worth of our best courses tools
templates and more just go to
thinkmediasale.com
[Music]